e
d'avortement du Mississippi
a fermé ...
confrontation.
La bataille judiciaire se jonnnn
Women's Health Center était
au coeur de la décision de
la Cour suprême de renverser
Une loi du Mississippi, adoptée
en 2018, rendait illégal
un avortement aprlinique l'a
contestée jusqu'au plus haut
tribunal du pays où elle
Ces manifestants anti-avortemene
cette femme.
les droits
des femmes qui souhaitent
obtenir un avortemun avortemun t
aux États-Unis, le président
Biden signe un décret qui
garantir l'accès à la piluleabo.
"Mais la façon la plus rapide,
dit-il, de rétablir la pratique
médicale dans tous les États
est d'adopter une loi fédérale.s
d'élus pro-choix as."
"Il y aions en
novembre. Votez, votez, votez",
dit-il aux Américains.
Le prés
particul aux femmes des
banlieues, l'un des électorats
les plus convoités. Elles ont
fait pencher la balance plus
souvent qu'à leur tour
ces dernières années.
Dans plusieurs États,
les Américains pourront fair
élire des gouverneurs comme
celui de la Caroline du Nord,
qui veut protéger le droit
ne devrait pas déterminer
quels sont vos droits."
Pourtant, cette clinique
fermée, rouvrira au Nouveau-
Mexique, où elle pourra
poursuivre des activités.
cet automne seront donc
déterminvortementvortementvortet
sera sans doute l'une
des questions les plus
importan
La bataille judiciaire est peut-
être terminée, maille
politique, elle, est bel et bien
engagée.
Ici Sébastien Desrosiers,
Radio-C